sticks sticks on your back I'm actually
kind of curious what sticks on your back
oh this little like thing that teeth
it's like this posture thing that I was
giving oh I need one leg and man I got
it and someone gave it to me for
Christmas and I was like really
insulting when you open it buddy like no
this is actually yeah yeah yeah it's a
good
so the lego movie - I feel like the
first lego movie sort of came out of
nowhere it just became this kid I mean
not so uh we knew it was great you spent
two years making it that's true and then
it came out into the world and we were
like yeah everybody Lego is amazing it's
really cool what was actually that's how
what the feeling was like on this one
going into it compared to going into the
first one well our expectations higher
there's a little more pressure because
the expectations are raised the end of
the lego movie 1 if you remember there's
this promise of a second movie that's
kind of likely between be between a
brother and a sister and in there
they're playing together I mean it's
really complicated to make a sequel to a
movie like lego movie because the lego
movie breaks the fourth wall at the end
and then that makes it really difficult
you kind of paint yourself into a corner
I remember thinking wait what prize is
out what could you possibly do but you
know luckily Chris and Phil the writers
are geniuses and they came up with a
really great way in and I feel now the
same way I felt during Lego one was just
really excited for the world to see what
we've been working on because it's just
it's it's awesome
something I really enjoy about to step
out about this one in particular is one
of the messages is that if everything is
not awesome all the time it's I don't
like this
sometimes not also and I'm wondering why
you think that's important for kids
going to see this movie why that's
something that's important for them to
get in their heads yeah that's a great I
think just mindfulness about the world
around them and actually being able to
deal with anxiety and stress but your
natural those fires happen that's not
awesome really right on right on cue
with those sirens yeah yeah it feels
like teaching kids coping strategies for
when growth is not awesome for when they
feel down or disappointed or upset about
something you know inevitably bad things
are gonna happen and that's human needs
being human and so I think this movie
allows for like the possibility that
when that happens like here's some
coping strategies for what you can do
and how you can look at the world in a
in a nice way and also reach out to
people and stay connected to people that
care about you right to get you to get
you through those times and a part of
growing up is is learning that life can
be tough and we're watching of course
Finn the young boy from the first movie
he's growing up a little bit he's got a
little sister who's young but he's now
growing up and and I think this cautions
kids from when they're growing up they
sometimes feel the impulse to late
themselves so that no one could hurt
them when in fact that isolation is
gonna be far more hurtful than anything
any dealing with you know someone else
and oftentimes you know there's someone
has reached out an olive branch and you
take it as it you you look at it you
think they're gonna hit you with it and
then you go live under the dryer for a
couple years and you wonder why you're
sad it's like no you know it's better
once you get to that stage as a kid
where you start to see the truth of the
world around you and there are yeah like
coping strategies reaching out
communicating listening and being
comfortable who you are
[Music]